in Kyle Texas which is 30 minutes from
Austin they tried to break the record
for most people named Kyle in one
location ever and I made that video
about a couple years ago about like guys
named Kyle huh I was like this like
[__] just it just a kid who just
loved punch and drive while drinking
Monsters just like just was a kid who
definitely was neglected by his parents
and huffed ax body spray and then so
they were doing a Kyle Meetup
and I was like dude how funny it would
be if I went to this Meetup dressed up
as my Kyle character so he did it I did
that was on Sunday yeah so that's the
video we're working on is that crazy it
was [__] nuts but it's like if it was
at the Kyle fair right so there was like
families and [__] there but there was
also 1700
people named Kyle registered and you
needed 2 300 to break the record so they
missed it they missed the record but
dude I'll tell you what I've never seen
dude that many calls we could have
[__] January 6 all over again dog we
could have taken over a [__] Vape
Shop Easy dude it was and what did they
do yeah what was it was their boost were
there like Kyle dude there was a drywall
Booth where you could duck duck Kyle or
whatever dude I don't even know what the
[__] we were in and out of there pretty
quick
um but there was a drywall Booth where
you could pay five dollars to punch some
drywall
um it was like half families and then
just half dudes named Kyle with nothing
better to do is it crazy to see them and
eat people named with one name in the
same place it is because they all look
like they were Kyle they all look like
bring up Kyle
yeah oh Kyle yes type in Kyle the most
common Kyle looking
yeah they all kind of look like they
would uh
you know they had pukushan necklaces at
one point oh yeah and they they got
sunburn easy type of type of fellow you
know it's not like blonde hair but it's
not brown it's kind of that like yeah
typing cut oh yeah there you go so
there's me right there so if you go to
Kyle Know Your Meme it's just there's my
house right there yeah oh God yeah
so I made this video like
maybe three or four years ago about a
guy's named Kyle and then so I just was
like this would be such a funny video it
was so stupid if we just went to the the
fair and so we got a video and like it
was very it was fun dude anytime people
see a camera and a microphone they
already get pretty like fired up but
then when Kyle see a camera they're like
this is my chance so dude they're going
wow they let me on stage and I got to
yell a bunch of [__] that's sick dude
yeah I was like it smells like Slim Jims
and broken homes
then they were like you're all right
Trevor Wallace yeah
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one